nouvelle aventure notre jeu plus ce
système sans monture au toit plutôt
cercle est complètement d'accord
s'intéresser aux clients l'accompagner
dans ses choix pour vendre des lunettes
l'activité commerciale de l'opticien
c'est aussi être spécialiste de
l'optique pour déterminer les bons
verres pour la bonne vision c'est vrai
besoin des doutes qu'on fait ne sais pas
si je voulais faire un salto à vos
dispositions que ça pourrait faire une
sélection des montures on va beaucoup
travailler quand elle après il ya tout
ce qui est en préparation des lunettes
préparation aussi de des livraisons non
entretien du magasin aimé le métier mais
aussi côté médical ce qu'on est quand
même en lien avec un aspect très mutera
médical 1 on a les yeux la santé
visuelle
c'est une chose très importante donc
faut être consciencieux
et puis rigoureux pour ses magasins
grandvision va proposer de nombreux
postes d'opticiens lors de sky emploi
avec différents profils recherchés
technicien optique ou vendeur un
opticien diplômé peut faire justement
tout ce qui est à vérification visuelle
et adaptation aux lentilles de contact
contrairement à l'opticien vendeurs pas
principalement faire des ventes vont
solaire rententi vente lunettes
des stages et des alternances sont aussi
proposés dans les magasins situés à
montigny le bretonneux le siège de
grands vision propose ce type de contrat
aux étudiants en marketing ressources
humaines ou communication des offres
disponibles le 4 avril prochain sur leur
stand lors du sky emploi